without facts you can't have truth
without truth you can't have trust
without this you have no shared reality
you don't have democracy you cannot
solve any problems globally and the hard
part is if social media is a behavior
modification system
then where does free will
or the choice of the candidate how can
you have integrity of elections
if you don't have integrity of facts
i think our elections is truly
emblematic of the impact of
disinformation um
[Music]
he won by an overwhelming number of
information operations that began as
early as 2014 this is these are the
networks that we've seen that literally
change the history of the philippines in
front of our eyes networks of
disinformation that turned marcos from a
pariah to a hero we will build back
better i i used the quote by milan
kundera the struggle of man against
power is the struggle of memory against
forgetting
and here in a short period of time we
watched our history overturned
and we
overwhelmingly elected marcos jr as
president
so by the 50th anniversary of the
declaration of martial law that will
happen in september this year
ferdinand marcos jr is the president of
the country it's
incredible what we're seeing are
illiberal style leaders elected with the
help of this technology that has
insidiously manipulated what voters
think around the world
they then elect an illiberal leader who
takes that power
democratically elected and crushes
democracy from within we're in the
upside down and a lot of that is because
impunity online
has seeped into impunity offline these
two worlds
the same being our minds our physical
beings we live in one world and the fact
that that
online
this kind of impunity of you know online
violence uh that that this is allowed to
happen
impacts the checks and balances
the rule of law in the real world and
that's what we're paying for
this isn't the first time this has
happened right like and this i go back
to
uh 1935 1936 we know the lessons of
history
and part of what i think took the world
by surprise
is that technology acted like fuel
an accelerant that
like lit dry kindling on fire and this
is what it feels like it almost feels
like we're in the last few years these
next few years will determine whether
democracy survives globally
you